the shoving into the limelight of Devon
Nunez by his harebrained involvement in
the FBI's investigation of possible
Trump Russia collusion has been
backfiring hilariously for him first he
exposed himself as a sort of hacky
partisan shill when while he was running
the house investigation into Trump
Russia collusion he went to the White
House to tell President Trump what was
going on in the investigation absolutely
ludicrous should have been removed from
Congress for it barely any consequences
for him then he writes this memo
summarizing intelligence he never saw
and as I broke down for you yesterday
the memo was released and even if
everything in the memo is true it
exposes nothing major that would impact
the integrity of Robert Mulder's
investigation and we don't even know if
the stuff in the memo is true but we
knew that it contained at least one
major lie about a statement made or I
guess in reality not made by former FBI
director James Comey in 2017 I went
through that lie yesterday I won't do it
again today but he straight-up
misrepresents what James Comey said and
now the cherry on top Nunez appeared on
Fox News's Fox and Friends and he
decided to make the claim that Donald
Trump has never met indicted Trump crony
George papadopolis and sadly that's what
we call a lie in the real world and
there's a picture of Trump and
Papadopoulos together and that picture
has been out for a while let's first
check out Devon Nunez who's becoming
incredibly proficient at digging himself
into holes on Fox and Friends whole
thing goes about a quarter page some say
well what about Papadopoulos they
started looking at him earlier what do
you say to that well I would say that if
Papadopoulos was such a major figure why
didn't you get a warrant on him you know
Papadopoulos was such a major figure you
had nothing on him you know the guy lied
as far as we can tell Papadopoulos never
even knew who Trump you know never even
had met with the president and and look
getting drunk
in London and talking to other than
talking to diplomats saying that you
don't like Hillary Clinton is really I
think it's kind of scary that our
intelligence agencies would take that
and use it against American citizen yeah
there is no spinning this whatsoever
right here is a picture of Papadopoulos
at a table of maybe ten people along
with Jeff Sessions and other high-level
advisors to Trump and this was a meeting
during which Papadopoulos was meeting
with Trump in his capacity as an advisor
now people have started trying to get
ahead of this saying well Nunez said met
with not met and met with suggests a
one-on-one meeting were there
individually hanging out but met just
means oh well they might have been in
the same place at the same time at some
point as unlikely as that is we don't
really need to wonder because Trump
himself said oh yeah George papadopolis
he's a great guy remember this audio
Walid Phares who you probably know PhD
advisor to the representatives caucus
and counterterrorism expert Carter page
PhD George papadopolis he's an oil and
energy consultant excellent excellent
so if they didn't know each other it's
an incredible series of coincidences
where Trump is lying or mistaken when he
says he knows Papadopoulos is an
excellent guy and even though they had
an advisory meeting and sat at the same
table they never spoke to each other nor
were introduced but yet Trump still knew
that he was an excellent guy the chain
of fact you have to believe to make
Devon noon as his statement correct is
just too long right Occam's razor
there's a much simpler explanation which
is they know each other they knew each
other and Devon Nunez is lying because
they want to put distance between a guy
who was indicted in the Trump Russia
investigation and Trump yeah I mean you
say that Devin eNOS was lying the other
possibility was that he just didn't know
that the meeting between Trump and
Papadopoulos and usually you rank lying
as worth worse than just not knowing
right I mean yes that malice versus
negligence and the law agrees with that
right perjury
you don't you're not gonna be a charged
with perjury if you don't remember
something or I don't know but the thing
here is that Devin Nunez is the chairman
of the House Intelligence Committee and
I'm working on this for a year yeah so
he should know more than I do and I knew
about this meeting that's exactly the
point if Joe down the street who's busy
working and supporting his family and
making vegan shakes or whatever he's
doing during the day if he doesn't know
the truth about Donald Trump and George
papadopolis his acquaintance who the
hell cares right is of no consequences
when Devin Nunez who was in a position
of real power here doesn't know
something as simple as an Indian vest
agait ssin did know Trump and was an
advisor to Trump and sat at a table with
Trump then were in real trouble and
Nunez has a habit of lying about
provable statements of facts misquoting
James Comey incorrectly stating that one
of the people indicted by Robert
Moeller's investigation never met Trump
and in fact he's becoming so blatantly
dishonest that not only is it
reminiscent of Trump I'm starting to
wonder whether Trump has something on
Nunez and that's why Nunez is behaving
so erratically but remember when you do
Trump's bidding Trump rewards you and
that's exactly what
has been doing Trump tweeting yesterday
about Devin Nunez representative Devin
unis a man of tremendous courage and
grit may someday be recognized as a
great American hero for what he has
exposed and what he has had to endure
very binary with Trump you live for him
and you're a hero you tell the FBI or
the American people or whoever the truth
and Trump goes after you like a rabid
dog
yeah and contrast that tweet with the
one about Adam Schiff the ranking member
on the House Intelligence right well
he's little Adam Schiff yeah which means
that Trump is starting to recycle his
insults I know it's getting old isn't it
it's depressing this is really bad we've
got to watch out of a knot Adam Schiff
we've got to watch Devon Nunez very very
closely the video you just watched was
made possible by support from you please
go to patreon.com slash david pakman
show you can make a pledge of as little
as $1 per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad